-Performing "King" from her new
album, "Dance Fever,"
please welcome
Florence + the Machine!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ We argue in the kitchen
about whether to have children ♪
♪ About the world ending
and the scale of my ambition ♪
♪ And how much
is art really worth ♪
♪ But The very thing
you're best at
is the thing
that hurts the most ♪
♪ But you need
your rotten heart,
your dazzling pain
like diamond rings ♪
♪ You need to go to war
to find material to sing ♪
♪ I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪ I need my
golden crown of sorrow ♪
♪ My bloody sword to swing ♪
♪ My empty halls to echo
with grand self-mythology ♪
♪ I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪ I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪ But a woman is a changeling,
always shifting shape ♪
♪ Just when you think you
have it figured out,
something new begins to take ♪
♪ What strange claws are
these scratching at my skin? ♪
♪ I never knew my killer
would be coming from within ♪
♪ I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪ I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪ I need my
golden crown of sorrow ♪
♪ My bloody sword to swing ♪
♪ I need my empty halls to
echo with grand self-mythology ♪
♪ 'Cause I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪ I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪ I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪ I am no mother ♪
♪ I am no bride ♪
♪ I am king ♪
♪♪
♪ Ohhhh ♪
♪ Oh, ohhhh, oh-ohhhh, oh-oh ♪
♪ Ohhhh, ooh ♪
♪♪
♪ I was never as good as
I always thought I was ♪
♪ But I knew how
to dress it up ♪
♪ I was never satisfied ♪
♪ It never let me go ♪
♪ Just dragged me by my hair ♪
♪ And back on with ♪
♪ The show ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]